[Music]
and moment of silence news shut up
[ __ ] submitted by to a mukbang
we did go check out Davis channel bans
friendly I thought milk bottles eat room
it's not his pong this stands for pong
so or it means like broadcast
0:08 broadcast eating broadcast my bad
people it's funny cuz like white people
corrected me a [ __ ] oh I thought it was
like bong like Norah bonds that's why I
thought too
oh and it kind of makes sense if it was
but it's nots like puzzle a Korean yeah
it's not a word so what about gang bang
is when you ride up on somebody gang
bang over 100 people showed up to a
light hearted vigil for a burned-down
Taco Bell Taco Bell please sponsor me I
think you guys have the best fast food
tacos ever I'm sorry Joe I agree yeah
it's okay I like the Mexican pizza cuz
[ __ ] you know what I was so mad that
Mexican pieces don't even exist
I thought that [ __ ] was like legit
Mexican food Oh like there's a real
thing and then they convert it to Taco
Bell how old we came up like it was the
real thing and then they just but it's
kind of like that [ __ ] that you get it
toggles on board although yeah yeah so
in Alabama I'll buy em all oh that's
like the only ethnic restaurant huh
chuckle bail that sounds volunteer yeah
so there was this Taco Bell that burned
down and someone thought it was really
funny if they could just do like a
candlelit vigil for this what exactly is
a vigil is when they had those likes
rosemary candles and [ __ ] you know when
someone dies on the street and all of
the homies come and put up those like
Catholic candles on the floor yeah they
just kind of leave the fire hazard there
for I see you know I really miss the old
Taco Bell logo when it was the Bell and
it just said Taco Bell in like that
Western ranch plant and it was like
these doodoo colors do you remember that
I remember the doodoo colors it was like
that reddish brown yeah yeah I missed
that no it's all purple and
futuristic-looking
first ever taught the Bellas and downing
is it McDonald's there no Adama that's
the oldest running that's still open
damn dowdy most fast food okay so anyway
so this vigil it was so funny so it was
like about a hundred people I shook why
are you laughing somebody said it's such
a soft cute boy that's my head yeah yeah
so anyways I grew up there so we're all
LA natives except for David's oh yeah
that's right you're on the transplant
sac town till I die macro Mentos
California represent so there were about
a hundred people that showed up to this
thing so this is the burndown Taco Bell
is a big the only 24-hour fast food
around why does it look like a CCTV
footage of someone that's about to do
some [ __ ] it's really bad it does like
he's like the bad guy oh yeah and then
here's the candlelight vigil does she
have her own just standing around and
then with their candles everyone's just
laughing like it was just so
light-hearted that's a cute way to bring
together the community that's what
people are saying like they were they
were making comments like that like this
is so awesome I love the fact that in my
town like we can all come together over
something so silly especially in times
like this trying to get distracted well
then you are making a mockery of vigils
and I don't appreciate it I love
community trolling social justice
warrior I love community trolling
community trolling is the best like when
people get together and then they do the
Flashdance
oh yes because [ __ ] so this is joint
called a b-26 tacos in LA that I [ __ ]
love to the life of me and then eater LA
or dine when I eat LA or whatever what
the [ __ ] is called LA yeah they they
said that it got oh [ __ ] you know but
they said that it got shut down I was
like what the [ __ ] and so I went over
there and it was open but Khalif got kin
for the vigil for Africa straight up the
99-cent store the one with like the
Virgin Mary and [ __ ] yeah we were gonna
do it and then they were there oh oh
[ __ ]
yeah so Avenue 26 is still there go eat
there those are my peoples hmm
shout out the Caesar that's tight so
then there was this even the singer that
she created so this is the singer she
said she did a song by Taco Bell song
last year the one with the green hair
she they even performed her Taco Bell
song who's that Frank Ocean in the back
oh yeah so I'm gonna play a little clip
of her Taco Bell so this was filmed at
this Taco Bell in that burnout oh here
we go
[Music]
[Laughter]
I will be sure my taco is
[Music]
[Music]
that's time
yeah that's almost the [ __ ] by the way
the Taco Bell sauce has changed they all
taste the same
oh I taste all of them none of them are
spicier than the other ones and they all
taste kind of the same to me they've
changed from the back in the day we did
huh
you can't handle spicy food oh no that's
Bart my dad oh [ __ ] I'm tripping right
now that was also a face to remember
that yeah you just kept on eating spies
I'm out of that phase now why cuz your
bajo Bart
it was weird no I don't know where this
food just like his food could just come
out red and I would just start something
else in it I had this crazy face like a
year or two ago now I'm just like I
still have a little bit of hot sauce
what the [ __ ] was that about it was a
weird face I don't know maybe I bacteria
in my stomach and my body wanted to burn
it you know what's funny though since I
ever since I came to LA have it had Taco
Bell why you know why cuz we have del
tacos is real tacos yeah you can't
compare it like I feel like it's too
deep I know it's a different experience
but it's just like if I'm craving a
mouthful I'm gonna go for the dollar
tacos it also I just found out that LA
has dollar fish taco spots change my
life I [ __ ] love this city but it's
like there's like dollar tacos fish
dollar tacos and then there's couple
Bell but if I'm gonna go to Taco Bell
I'm gonna go to del Taco the sponsor in
Bell Taco just give him a little fun I
think we're too pushy I think we just
need to back off that's a big Donald's I
want to be all up in there we just need
to back off a little bit I love Taco
Bell del Taco responds to me on Twitter
every single time that's all I need
so you don't go right they don't have
money okay I know they don't have money
that's why I don't care I'm gonna do a
video where I just literally talk [ __ ]
about McDonald's so um do you know what
I'm gonna do it
people's gonna happen is that I'm a talk
[ __ ] about McDonald's and they're gonna
in spite of me they're gonna give you
guys a sponsorship
she doesn't she doesn't count she got
titties and [ __ ] I can't I can't barely
know they'll never sponsor us I don't
care anymore I don't care because I'm
ready to jump ship and move on to other
places Goodwill [ __ ] McDonald's you
delicious yeah that's way now we're
talking about the will oh well if you
sponsor us do you have any idea the
fervor you're gonna create because we've
been on McDonald's dick for a long-ass
time and they won't let us ride that
dick at all del Taco
yeah I know tim has a relationship with
Taco Bell to like he he's gotten invited
to like the friend giving thing you know
what that [ __ ] was about that was that
fried one the chalupa that [ __ ] is
number six to steak chalupas with the
hardshell Park on the side but you know
what Taco Bell doesn't have chili cheese
fries nor do they have coke I know
that's true I like Pepsi that Pepsi
you know I used to like Pepsi more than
I like coke now I love coke way more
than I like what happened
that's it is like medicine I mean do you
know what happened to me no you [ __ ]
because you guys kept on getting coke
and I was like it turns out coke with
extra I used to be a Pepsi person until
mark I'm your addicted to coke you guys
are the Pepsi challenge
most people think Pepsi tastes better
than coke even within the people that
work at Coke the company but it's the
marketing and that red can and
everything that makes the coke so much
more delicious but if you do the Pepsi
challenge people typically like the
flavor it's just the way this fool
drinks coke that maybe wanted so much
this was like but I think it's the
diluted cope that I like because once
you do the ice to the top I don't like
coke straight up from the can or the
bottle 50 yeah only Mexican Coke is is
good straight up have you tried to cope
with the natural cane sugar which is
pretty much my skin color but the green
label one no that's debía or like yeah
the green label coke is like
is a Stears nothing is nested or they
use different kinds of sugars has that
nasty aftertaste when I first had stevia
I spit that [ __ ] out and then I punched
the person who gave it
it's like cactus sugar or some [ __ ] I
don't know it comes from Satan's [ __ ]
tear ducts I hate that [ __ ] dude I'm
opposite like I'd like coke first I'll
talk first and then I like Pepsi just
because like Pepsi has less carbonation
in it and like I have trouble burping
like on command so we need someone a
[ __ ] burp you because when I try to
do it it just sounds like I'm throwing
up cuz I'm like but oh you get the
bubbly water Ebert yeah
what are those I'm like don't think
you're about to throw up yeah I just get
stuck in my throat right here and it
just keeps rolling up but never comes
out I never had a let's call barf it
just feels like air and like I just want
to burp it but I can't so that I'll like
every time we we go out to eat we'll
make sure to disbar pew then I thought
you do it on my lap thank you
I need that extra help on your shoulder
too
[Music]